hello Ukrainian officials are saying
that Russia launched a major missile
strike on the Central City of creary
overnight at least six people have been
reported dead and dozens injured the
mayor says rescue operations are still
underway as several people are believed
to be trapped under the rubble and he
added that a residential building and a
Food Warehouse were hit meanwhile in
Kiev military officials say air defenses
destroyed all Russian missiles targeting
the capital
rescue operations continued to clear the
remnants of this barbaric missile attack
the Russian forces used six missiles
five of which were destroyed the missile
targeted an area where there is no
military presence and hit the
residential building and a Food
Warehouse let's get an update from Keith
Jonah hallo standing by for us so Jonah
tell us about these strikes that took
place overnight
well probably not coincidental with
reports of modest gains being made by
the ukrainians in their
counter-offensive Russia now having
sadly some success of their own
Ukrainian military talking about as you
mentioned their 14 cruise missiles fired
overnight as a nationwide air raid alert
was put in place that was in the early
hours of Tuesday morning also for
Iranian made drones as is usually the
case most of those shot down uh by air
defenses 11 of the missiles downed one
of the drones but some of them did reach
targets uh targets hitting kharkiv
civilian business infrastructure hit
there no word of casualties but of
course the big strike was in Creve that
Central City it's the hometown of
President zielinski a five-story
apartment building uh hit there beside a
warehouse that was also struck and
frantic rescue efforts underway the
latest death toll according to the local
Administration is six they believe
people are stuck under the rubble and
taking to telegram to say this the
terrorists will never be forgiven they
will be held accountable for every
missile they launch and Jonah zielinski
has also spoken about the progress of
the counter-offensive according to him
what did he have to say
but he did that in his nightly address
his first comments uh since Saturday
when he admitted the counter-offensive
had actually uh begun and that alongside
reports from the defense Ministry that
some seven Villages have now been taken
in the course of the last week retake
and that is in the course of the last
week he said fighting was tough he
thanked and praised the forces involved
he said we are moving forward now four
of those Villages are the ones we've
been hearing about in the last couple of
days on the East and West Bank of the
mockery alley River in the southern
donets Province uh the most successful
axis thus far heading south in the
general direction of Mario pole they've
got a long way to go of course if that
is indeed their intended route to try
and divide Russian forces uh down there
in the South but I must say there are
also reports of Russia launching a
pretty significant counter-attack in the
area on Monday no details of that though
available here in Kiev okay thank you so
much Jonah hall for that update from
Keith